anyone that embarks into the art and
even if you're not an artist or a
performer in the art of living as an
extension will have the most difficult
life because it's the opposite of
lethargy and laziness and dragging your
feet and and and dying as you live so if
you want your life to be exciting if you
find the mater necessary for a great
life which is passion you will have a
difficult life and at the same time your
life will be very easy in a sense that
you will not have to struggle to find
ways it is in you it divorce you you
have to do it using your intuition and
your passion so for example well people
sometime ask me you know what how can I
be creative or I want to be I am a young
artist and I want to develop my art and
right there I built a big wall between
two concept that to me are very opposite
the concept of a career and the concept
of life so if somebody says you know
you're started career as an actor do you
have any advice I say yes drop the word
carrier from your vocabulary live as an
actor you know don't try to do things in
a study strategy way do things as your
heart tells you if you feel you're a
comic character do not accept in a drama
go into the comic and start developing
it the work of art is a is a perpetual
trampoline
it is it is ephemeral it is fragile it
is mysterious there is no rule to
describe what a an artistic way of life
is so if you want to go in an artistic
way of life and you carry the luggage of
money and time and strategy and politics
and well you will never be an artist you
know but it's fine many false artists
are doing that but the true artists in
my opinion should not think of a career
you should think of your life
you